عرف بيريدولف ابل لكنه في الحقيقه ويليام
فيشر الذي لم يرث الشيوعيه عن ابيه فحسب
بل وتحلى بمهارات وقدرات جعلته مؤهلا
ليصبح الجاسوس الاحمر الاكثر خطوره خلال
الحرب البارده كيف لا وقد اسهمت عمالته في
صناعه اول قنبله ذريه سوفيتيه بالتاريخ
فما قصته ولد ويليام فيششر المعروف
بيرودولف ابل عام
1903 في انجلترا لام روسيه واب الماني كان
لاجئين هرب من روسيا القيصريه فوالده
جينيرك فيشر كان صديق لينين حيث امضى 20
عاما في العمل على نشر عقيده لينين قبل
العوده الى روسيا حصل ويليام على منح
دراسيه في مسيرته التعليميه وتميز
بايجادته اللغات الانجليزيه والالمانيه
والبولنديه والياديشيه والروسيه
عاد مع عائلتي بعد الثوره الروسيه عام
1921 هناك انضم للجيش الاحمر بوظيفه مشغل
راديو فعمل في النرويج وتركيا والمملكه
المتحده وفرنسا بعد ذلك تولى رئاسه وحده
تدرب مشغل الراديو على المهام غير
القانونيه وكان له دور كبير في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه حيث شارك في عمليات سريه
خلف الخطوط الالمانيه النازيه بعد الحرب
اختير ويليام لمهمه احياء شبكه عملاء
السوفييت في الولايات المتحده حيث ارسل
الى هناك بطريقه غير شرعيه في عام
1948 عمل بدون غطاء دبلوماسي كمحرر للصور
فيما كان فريقه الذي كان من ضمنه لونا
كوهين وتيتهول يجمع اسرار القنبله الذريه
من مشروع منهات عمل ويليام لمده تسع سنوات
في التجسس استخدم خلالها خمسه اسماء وهميه
على الاقل
كما نقل معلومات ثريه للاتحاد السوفيتي
اسهمت بشكل كبير في تسريع انجاز اول قنبله
ذريه سوفيتيه لكن في عام
1957 وقع بقبضه مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه
وحكم عليه بالسجن لمده 30 عاما في العاشر
من فبراير عام
1962 تم تبادله مع فرانسيس جالي باورز
الذي احتجز في المانيا الشرقيه منذ عام
1960 بتهمه قياده طائره تجسس امريكيه فوق
المجال الجوي السوفيتي فعاد الى موسكو
وقام بالقاء الخطب والمحاضرات للطلاب حول
انشطه الاستخبارات كما ظهر في فيلم تجسس
سوفيتي بعنوان ضد سيزون وعمل ايضا مستشارا
في الفيلم قبل وفاته بسبب سرطان الرئه في
الخامسه عشر من نوفمبر عام 1971
حيث كتب على قبره
الجاسوس الذي لا ينكسر